hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an Italian comedy film called
put grandma in the freezer spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie opens up in a church where a
young man and an extremely old woman are
getting married by the looks of her
physical condition it is possible that
she won't even survive the week the
priest clearly doesn't approve of the
marriage so he taunts the man for going
through all this trouble just to get the
woman's pension he also makes comments
about the people present in the room who
appear to be criminals paid to witness
the wedding just then the priest removes
his disguise and Reveals His real
identity he is Simone an undercover law
enforcement officer he arrests the groom
for trying to commit fraud and takes him
away what if he really loved her though
the scene then cuts to a museum where a
woman named Claudia threatens to destroy
a historical painting if her demands
aren't met she gathers the media and
reveals that she is an art restorer
Claudia's business has been on the verge
of bankruptcy because the museum owes
her more than a hundred thousand dollars
now she is entirely dependent on her
grandmother Bridget's pension to support
herself suddenly her friends Rosanna and
Margie Margie Margie Margie interrupt
her press conference and mentioned that
Bridget's health is in critical
condition therefore Claudia is forced to
abandon her plan and return home however
on reaching it she then learns that
Bridget was just being dramatic and she
only had some acidity the old woman says
that she is ready to die but she is
worried about Claudia's future hearing
this the latter becomes emotional and
heads to the kitchen to prepare
something to eat but right then all the
lights in the house go out and when the
power is restored Claudia learns that
Bridget has passed away she lived for 90
years through two brutal Wars The Great
Depression and several famines but in
the end a minor power outage killed her
well that and being old as [__] Claudia
is devastated that her only family
member has passed away but she is even
more worried about the future of her
business seeing her upset Rosanna offers
her condolences and comes up with a
Sinister plan she suggests that they
keep Bridget's body in the freezer so
the pension money keeps on coming they
will only have to do this until the
museum pays off their remaining money
Claudia is horrified by the advice and
says that she can't do that to her dead
grandmother however Rosanna explains
that it's the only solution and that
they can give Bridget a proper burial
once they recover the money from the
museum after much deliberation Claudia
reluctantly agrees and the friends put
Bridget's body in the freezer before
covering it with steak and pasta I'm
hungry now and I don't like steak or
pasta the following day Claudia goes to
the pension office to receive the
monthly check but the officer tells her
to wait for a month because she's on a
waiting list however the officer offers
to speed up the process if she agrees to
pay him off this infuriates Claudia and
she berates him for being a corrupt
person suddenly the armor of a warrior
behind Claudia starts to move and he is
revealed to be Simone who is on another
undercover operation after catching the
corrupt officer red-handed Simone
arrests him and whisks him away Claudia
rushes after them with some paper asking
the officer for his signature so she can
receive the pension this is when Simone
finally notices Claudia's Beauty and he
is instantly smitten however he quickly
snaps out of it and tells her that the
officer can't sign the papers this leads
to an argument and as they go back and
forth Claudia unintentionally pushes him
down the stairs injuring him badly later
a remorseful Claudia visits Simone in
the hospital to apologize she first
introduces herself and then explains the
immense Financial pressure she is under
thanks to the delayed payment at this
point Simone has developed a full-blown
crush on Claudia so he agrees not to
pursue a case against her meanwhile his
Juniors watch him talk with the
beautiful girl and instantly deduce that
he likes her it is then revealed that
Simone got divorced some months ago and
to cope with the pain he's become a
workaholic he also forces his Juniors to
work longer hours frustrating their
lives therefore Simone's Juniors plan to
set him up with Claudia and make him a
fun-loving Carefree person once again
they take him to a bar and try to send
him to Claudia's home under the pretense
of investigating her grandmother's
pension case that's what I call it too
however Simone quickly figures out their
intentions and warns them against
playing games with him refusing to give
up the Juniors then get him drunk and
make him open up Simone finally reveals
that he stays away from women because he
has lost the confidence to speak with
them after getting left by his ex-wife
but after a lot of convincing Simone
finally agrees to pay Claudia a visit
the following day when he arrives at the
door Claudia is taken aback to see him
she quickly covers the freezer before
letting him in both of them are nervous
to see each other and when she inquires
about the reason for his visit Simone
panics and tells her that he came to
meet her grandmother in regards to the
pension case hearing this Claudia
becomes certain that the cops are onto
her but fortunately she manages to send
Simone Away by lying that her
grandmother has gone to her Village
Claudia then tells her friends about
Simone's visit and together they decide
to drop their plan and give Bridget a
funeral to avoid jail time however they
are forced to wait as it will take the
dead body 15 hours to completely thaw
before they can take her to a doctor and
register her death as they wait Claudia
gets a call from someone named Augusto
who asks her about the grandmother
frightens her even more so she tells him
that she's busy and hangs up the call
meanwhile Simone's Juniors inquire about
his visit to Claudia's home and he
admits that he couldn't ask her out they
then advise him to try again by
imagining Claudia as a criminal this is
because Simone always gets motivated
when he is on duty you know what I'm
saying later he takes their advice and
pays Claudia another visit catching the
girls totally off guard Rosanna and
Margie scramble to hide the body while
Claudia answers the door she tries to
shoe him away by making several excuses
but the officer is adamant on coming in
left with no choice Claudia allows him
inside and nervously looks back to her
relief Rosanna and Margie have already
taken care of the deceased Woman by
applying makeup to her face she is now
sitting on the table looking completely
alive and well Simone greets Bridget
cheerfully but before he can get a reply
Claudia quickly takes him to another
room there he finally admits that he has
liked her ever since their first meeting
In the Heat of the Moment he also asks
her out but quickly regrets it wondering
if he has overstepped his bound
boundaries to his astonishment Claudia
says yes not because she likes him but
because she wants him out of the house
however the date does not go as planned
because Simone bores the hell out of
Claudia with his work-related stories
later she calls her friends for an
update and they tell her that they put
the body back in the freezer because
something came up and they had to leave
the house after the date Simone walks
her back home and prepares to leave when
suddenly a dog starts chasing them as a
result he again enters the house the
power is out so Claudia tells him to
wait by the door as she goes to get a
candle when she returns she notices him
inspecting the refrigerator to check if
food has been spoiled to distract him
she frantically starts kissing him and
then takes him to her bedroom this is
the first time thinking about your
grandparents has ever made someone more
horny when things start to heat up
Claudia backs down saying that they
should take things slow Simone being a
gentleman agrees and returns home
however he incessantly messages her and
Claudia feels stuck therefore she
devises a plan to get rid of him that
evening she goes on a date add in a
revealing dress and a lot of makeup she
acts obnoxious and deliberately picks
fights with other guests as a result one
of the guests punches Simone in the face
the latter is puzzled by her behavior
and he finally ends the date when she
grabs his crotch and asks him to show
the junk the following day Augusta the
caller arrives at Claudia's home he
reveals that he is Bridget's old friend
and demands to meet her Claudia tries to
make excuses to get rid of him but he
tells her that he has been camping in
the neighborhood for three days but he
didn't see Bridget even once he then
warns her that if he doesn't see Bridget
by tomorrow he will call the police
afraid of getting exposed Claudia and
her friends come up with a plan the
following day when Augusto shows up at
the door Claudia disguises herself as
Bridget and speaks to him fortunately he
doesn't recognize her and it's revealed
that Bridget nagusto used to date in the
past Augusto says that his wife has
passed away and he wants to get together
with her however Claudia tells him that
she has found someone else and sends him
away after getting rid of him she
finally breathes a sigh of relief but
the doorbell again rings to her dismay
it is Simone she nervously tells him
that Claudia is at work but the cop
wants to speak with Bridget instead left
with no choice Claudia lets him in and
Simone expresses his feelings for her he
says he's aware that Claudia
deliberately put on the schizophrenic
Avatar to scare him away but he is not
going anywhere because he really loves
her hearing all this Claudia is moved so
she asks him to wait for a while she
then rushes to the garage to remove her
makeup after returning back to her real
self she walks up to Simone and kisses
impassionately the two then make love
and decide to go on a vacation Simone's
juniors are elated and they throw a
party to celebrate meanwhile during the
vacation Claudia and Simone get to know
each other and it is revealed that
Simone's marriage broke down because he
caught his ex-wife committing tax fraud
the amount wasn't even that big just 3
000 Euros Simone then warns Claudia to
never compel him to choose between her
and his duty because he will always pick
the latter what a friggin dork a month
later Claudia returns from vacation and
reveals to her friends that she's
pregnant she also expresses her fear
that Simone will break up with her if he
finds out about Bridget's body therefore
they all agree to bury Bridget's body as
soon as possible in the next scene
Simone is on another undercover Mission
Claudia and her girls load Bridget's
body into the van and prepare to take
her to the cemetery however on their way
there they are pulled over by Simone's
Juniors on grounds of speeding they
don't recognize Claudia and demand to
see the back of the van when the girls
refuse to comply Simone is called to the
scene it turns out that he and his team
are currently looking for a gangster
Claudia tries to emotionally blackmail
Simone but it doesn't work and he slowly
opens up the door surprisingly the body
is nowhere to be found it is then
revealed that somewhere along the Route
a speed breaker yanked the door open and
the dead body in the wheelchair rolled
out of the van coincidentally Augusto
who happened to be around noticed
Bridget and started following her
meanwhile Margie accidentally slips out
that there was an old woman in the back
of the van forcing Claudia to make up a
story that they were actually
transporting a statue unfortunately
Simone accuses them of stealing the
statue from the museum he then arrests
the girls but instead of taking them to
the police station he takes them to an
isolated location there Simone reveals
that he had always suspected Claudia of
hiding her grandma in the freezer he is
now in a deep dilemma as he has to
choose between his love and his duty
what a dork however after much
consideration he decides that he does
not want his baby to be born in prison
so he agrees to overlook the crime he
breaks up with Claudia but when he
learns that the body has gone missing he
is forced to help Simone and the girls
then split up and start looking for the
body meanwhile after rolling through
town Bridget's body comes to a stop in a
forest Augusta also arrives but when he
learns that the love of his life is dead
he suffers a heart attack and passes
away after a while Margie and Rosanna
eventually arrive at the location and
find the bodies they first decide to
take care of augusto's body but when
they return Bridget is once again gone
panicked they rush to is home and inform
her of everything just when it appears
that the girls are going to jail they
spot the body right next to the gate
however suddenly some officers arrive
there and suspect that the person in the
wheelchair is the gangster they are
looking for the girls again panic but to
their relief the person is revealed to
be a statue after the police leave
Claudia goes back inside her house and
there she finds Bridget laying in her
bed Simone also arrives and it is
revealed that he found the body in the
woods and covertly brought it home
without telling his Juniors realizing
that he risked his career to save her
from the authorities Claudia hugs him
affectionately and the two reconcile
Claudia then promises to call a doctor
and bury her grandmother but Simone
tells her that the body must be
preserved in methanol for two days to
throw off the doctor about the actual
time of death it's creepy that he knows
that in the final scene Claudia and the
group attend augusto's funeral and pay
their respects later they discuss
Claudia's debt and her baby on the way
Simone realizes that his salary won't be
enough to keep the family afloat hence
he too agrees to make a compromise the
movie ends as Claudia Simone Margie and
Rosanna decide to freeze the granny for
a few more years subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching